well hello
hello
it's the whole aesthetic for me yeah
okay so you guys are performing tonight
are you nervous at all
no more excited
yeah we're excited
do you have a fear that just replays in
your mind mine is like tripping what's
yours nothing creepy no i don't think
about that otherwise it won't be the
worst
if i drew it just
save it right
um jayla's being honored tonight is
there an iconic jlo moment that sticks
out in your mind
i don't know she's iconic and everything
she does
i would say i would say like the the
latest that it comes to my mind i don't
remember i think it was the megala with
the green dress yes
there she was yes do you have an
astonishing astonishing i'm still i'm
still generally michael just can be
iconic himself
yes okay if the world were to end and
you could only listen to one artist or
one band for the rest of your life
oh
who would you pick
okay
because i i'm thinking about it i don't
know i think i
would go with james arthur
i would go with fleetwood mac maybe
i like that interesting interesting
that's a great tough person by the way i
don't know um
maybe
[Laughter]
okay okay and lastly anybody you're
excited to meet tonight
[Laughter]
oh awesome well thank you it was so nice
to meet you guys and i just love the
aesthetic